so I got some good and bad news and
since we're in England we'll start with
the good news because we always need to
end with the bad news um the good news
from your point of view and of course
I'm arguing that we should be scared but
there's one thing we shouldn't be scared
of we don't need to fear that in 20 or
30 or even 50
years we will become as human beings
indistinguishable from computers in
other words in 50 years we could all be
here could be like a science fiction
movie and we won't know whether you're
sitting next to a computer or not so
that's the good news you don't have to
worry about
Singularity but that doesn't mean we
should not be fearful of robots that
doesn't mean that we have a lot to be
scared about just because we're not
about to become indistinguishable from
robots doesn't mean they're about to
take away our livelihood and I'm
guessing that many many of you are
lawyers or doctors journalists people
trained in a field you probably went to
University you spent years acquiring
your intelligence your skill your
intellect and you sell that skill as a
teacher as a doctor as an accountant as
a lawyer your value in the economy is
based on that
expertise and it is you I'm afraid who
have the most to fear from this great
Revolution the digital Revolution which
one set of economists call our second
Machine age because this is as profound
as Earth shaking as culturally socially
and above all else economically profound
as the first industrial revolution of
the 19th century what we're on the brink
of is a world of increasingly intense
sophisticated artificial intelligence in
Silicon Valley where I'm from we call it
the machine learning Revolution it's the
revolution of algorithms not the
traditional science fiction
old-fashioned HG Wells notion Doctor Who
of the robot trundling along the street
the dalic get that image out of your
mind think of the algorithm think of the
self-driving car think of Google think
of these incredible new tech
Technologies which are coming out of
Silicon Valley which are essentially
replacing human labor skilled human
labor because here's the
Paradox it's really hard for computers
to replicate what seems to us to be
simple tasks simple tasks like doing the
garden the washing up cooking cutting
someone's
hair but on the other hand and here is
the dark scary horrific element to the
new world we're about to enter it's not
difficult to do what seems to us at
least to be the difficult things the bad
news and this is really bad news for
most of you and especially for your kids
because they are trying to follow in
your footsteps is that this world is
about to be swept
away by the digital Revolution machines
will learn how to diagnose diseases what
does that say for all doctors around the
world we already have software now that
grades essays What Becomes of school
teachers What Becomes of University
teachers two researchers at Oxford
University have argued that over the
next 10 years 47% of our jobs will
become irrelevant and those 47% I'm
afraid for you guys are your kind of
jobs and it's not just skilled labor
it's not just the professional class
it's not just those people who have been
fortunate or unfortunate enough to go to
university we have a large audience a
television audience from the developing
World these are people who are embracing
education who see it as a way out of
poverty I'm afraid the news is really
troubling for them because they missed
the bus development which was always
taken for Grant granted no longer will
happen and we have these increasing
inequalities in Silicon Valley because
all the wealth is going to the platform
companies all the wealth is going to
companies like Amazon and Google and the
other companies that have harnessed this
technology for their own benefit what
we're seeing is a hollowing out of the
middle class A hollowing out of the kind
of jobs that you guys have depended on
and a replac M by the algorithm by the
machine and by a tiny group of people
who own and control that machine that's
the reason I'm afraid why you should be
afraid very afraid thank
you thank you very much so our second
speaker is uh speaking against the
motion water isacson and W became famous
for his internationally acclaimed book
on the life of Steve Jobs and he gained
unprecedented access to Steve Jobs in
the last months of his life he's also
president and CEO of the Aspen Institute
in Washington and a former chairman and
CEO of CNN and the managing editor of
Time Magazine how do you fit it all in
thank you for making the time for us
today your time starts when you get to
the election thank
you
all very much and I have good news for
you and good news the good news is you
don't have to be afraid and the other
piece of good news is there's no bad
news in this the future is really going
to be cool uh since my uh since my
distinguished opponent Mr Keane started
with the Industrial Revolution and said
that this new Revolution would be as
disruptive as the Industrial Revolution
let me Begin by reminding you that the
Industrial Revolution wasn't all that
bad and at the end of it we had more
jobs not fewer jobs technology can
indeed be disruptive it can disrupt
certain jobs as Mr Keen has said but it
always has and I submit always will
produce more jobs because it produces
more wealth more personal income more
per capita wealth and thus more things
that we can make and buy uh every
succeeding generation has had a new wave
of worry uh dire warnings that jobs are
being threatened but in each one of
these cases they turned out to be wrong
I was at Time Magazine I went back to
look 50 years ago 50 years ago to this
date almost Time Magazine did a cover
just like this just like the uh line
that we're looking at it said the robots
are coming automation will take your job
it quoted a rather famous um economic
historian Robert hbr or most of you have
heard of him he says the new technology
is threatening a whole new group of
skills sounded just like Mr Kean he said
the calculating the remembering the
comparing the okaying skills The
Preserve of the office worker will go
away and machines will invade Society to
make that type of human labor redundant
well guess what it's been 50 years and
since then soon after he wrote that we
had the greatest leaps of Technology you
can imagine the internet the personal
computer and the microprocessor all come
into play but nobody has been rendered
redundant there's more jobs and more
types of jobs now than there were 50
years ago as Mark Andreas the person who
invented the uh web browser said just as
most of us today have jobs that weren't
invented a hundred years ago the same
will be true a 100 years from now let me
give some examples there's the app
economy it began in 2008 when Steve Jobs
was convinced by other members of his
management team to allow Outsiders to
create apps for the iPhone and then the
iPad the App Store alone since then has
created
627,000 jobs the app economy last year
was a hundred billion far surpassing the
film industry this is an industry that
did not exist 7even years ago uh other
advances in technology have helped
facilitate new forms of work such as the
sharing economy where people both here
New York New Orleans can drive cars be
part of uber be part of Airbnb be part
of Lyft likewise Online Marketplace such
as Amazon and eBay have enabled the rise
of Artisans makers the type of people
that exist in the pre-industrial age
people who had creative instincts and
then could have connections to customers
around the world if if you create a book
or a song now you have new ways to
publish as Pippa did with her own book
new ways to distribute if you dream up a
new
specialty this world allows you to find
customers and provide a service
just as if you were an artisan or
service maker in the pre-industrial
revolution it even helps long establish
companies find markets all over the
globe there's a more fundamental shift
going on in the economy that's also good
we're creating an on demand or ontap
economy if you need a housekeeper or a
handyman you don't have to go to a
particular firm to get it it can be done
on tap if new technology
reduce the total number of jobs we'd all
be out of work now and I doubt that Mr
Kean nor I nor you can guess what
wondrous jobs technology will bring to
our great grandchildren thank
you thank you very much indeed Walter
our second speaker for the motion is
Economist George Magnus after a long
career in finance in the city of London
um George is has turned to writing and
he's written the age of Aging a study of
how demographics are changing the world
economy and social systems so George
please make your way to the lecturn and
um tell us what you
think thank you very much uh so we're
going to talk economics now okay not
populism
so and what I'd like to put to you this
evening is that these digital and
robotic Technologies constitute a very
powerful economic threat to our
livelihoods because of its effect on
jobs on income distribution and because
they demand that we focus on coping
mechanisms that we do not yet
have now our opponents in this debate
and uh you've already heard the first
will try to convince you that because
mankind has always adapted to new
technologies historically we shouldn't
fear the robotic Revolution but this
time as they say it really is different
and I'm going to tell you why so just
over 200 years ago 64 men went on trial
in York these Lites they went on a
rampage they burned Mills and machinery
and so on but their campaign as we know
was myopic because the Industrial
Revolution or the first Industrial
Revolution did leave us all better off
what we did is we harnessed power and
that exposed the limits of human Brawn
but it was also complimentary to human
endeavor this is the key point it
allowed us to blend men and machines in
ways which boosted employment growth
income and sustained a rising and
prosperous middle class the modern
technological Revolution is different
it's exposing the limits not of human
Brawn but of human
brain uh and instead of being
complimentary modern technology is
displacing us uh capital is being
substituted more and more for labor
threatening jobs living standards and as
we know from contemporary political
debate the fabric of the middle class
not all jobs of course are at risk as
you've already heard machines are not
sufficiently dextrous to do all kinds of
manual work and lots of human uh
cognitive and judgmental skills have not
been uh replicated by machines and may
not but they've already been doing
routine based or rule-based jobs on the
factory floor and in offices for some
time since 2010 the number of low paying
and high-paying jobs has gone up but the
number of middle level jobs middle wage
paying jobs has stagnated or dropped in
a pattern that is replicated across the
whole of Europe in the United States
States and indeed in some emerging
countries notably in China and India
successful capitalism needs us to be
fully engaged not just as Gadget
savoring consumers which we all are but
also as producers in other words we need
to have stable productive high levels of
employment which is what robotics is
undermining and because capitalism
rewards scarcity and because the
robotics Revolution is generating
productivity gains that are benefiting a
limited number of people the principal
rewards of modern technology are
accruing to the owners of capital not
the owners of Labor in the main think
about the three biggest firms in Silicon
Valley they have
137,000 people and these three companies
have a market capitalization other words
they're worth uh $1.2 trillion now just
cast your mind back 25 years to 1990 the
three biggest companies in Detroit had
10 times as many workers 1.2 million and
their combined market value was a mere
36 billion dollar this fundamental
change in the relationship between
capital and labor is also illustrated by
what we see in lots of surveys about the
rising share of profits in national
income and the declining share of
wages because as economic inequality
Rises so political inequality Rises and
those that benefit from more political
power obviously seek changes which
further their own economic advantage and
you could easily end up without coping
mechanisms at a very kind of dystopian
political future I would remind you of
the quip from Lord KES the famous
British Economist who quipped that in
the long run we're all dead by which he
meant that the economists focus on the
longrun equilibrium was a waste of time
because economic circumstances affect us
now next year in the next few years not
at some vague point in the unmeasurable
future and that's really what is
important and brings me to my final
point which is that we need to think
about this really seriously and try to
develop coping mechanisms there could be
many uh better education better training
improved access to Capital job
protection schemes for certain
occupations higher minimum wage direct
transfers labor intensive construction
taxation of capital to help displaced
workers and so on I'm not commending
ladies and gentlemen any particular
coping mechanism to you tonight merely
pointing out that we have few and need
many as the robotics Revolution
evolves